john good morning and this is la bonita  supermarkets at eastern ndi where the  front of the parking lot the front  entrance to the grocery store you can  see  you can't walk inside part of the  roofing and the front part of this  building just collapsed you can see the  top missing a whole chunk of the front  part of this building and as we pan down  to the ground  we see a whole bunch of roofing we have  insulation we have a bunch of pieces  from the roofing and in the middle of  the parking lot actually i spotted a  pipe we don't know what caused all this  to come crashing down or if there are  any injuries but we do know a lot when  you're not supermarkets it's usually  open early in the morning according to  our google maps it opens at six o'clock  we've been inside before plenty of  people drinking coffee getting breakfast  or doing the grocery store shopping  anyway we'll be on the scene to get more  updates we'll have those throughout the  morning for